Very many of us suffer from a peculiar-sounding
problem: an inability properly to inhabit
the stretch of time we call ‘the present’.
Maybe we’re on a beautiful beach on a sunny
day, the sky is azure and the palm trees slender
and implausibly delicate, but most of ‘us’
isn’t actually here at all, it’s somewhere
at work or in imaginary discussion with a
rival or plotting a new enterprise. Or maybe
we’re at the birthday of a child: it’s
enormously significant for her and we love
her dearly, but we are elsewhere; our body
is rooted in the now, but our minds are skipping
to points in both the future and in the past.
What is it that makes the present, especially
the nicer moments of the present, so difficult
to experience properly? And why, conversely,
can so many events feel easier to enjoy, appreciate
and perceive, when they are firmly over? One
benefit of the past is that it is a dramatically
foreshortened edited version of the present.
Even the best days of our lives contain a
range of dull and uncomfortable moments. But
in memory, like skilled editors of hours of
raw and often uninspired footage, we lock
on to the most consequential moments; and
therefore construct sequences that feel a
great deal more meaningful and interesting
than the settings that generated them. Hours
of mediocrity can be reduced to five or six perfect
images. Nostalgia is the present enhanced
by an editing machine. Much of what ruins
the present is sheer anxiety. The present
always contains an enormous number of possibilities,
some hugely gruesome, which we are constantly
aware of in the background. Anything could
theoretically happen, an earthquake, an aneurysm,
a rejection – which gives rise to the non-specific
anxiety that trails most of us around all
the time; the simple dread at the unknownness
of what is to come. But then, of course, only
a very limited range of awful things do ever
come to pass and we forget the anxiety at
once (or rather shift it to the new present).
So when we remember an event, what we leave
out of it is how much of that event we actually
spent anticipating an appalling future that
never came. Our bodies further contribute
to our distraction from the present. They
have their own moods and itineraries. They
might feel tired and timid at just the moment
when the landscape around us would demand
grandeur and confidence. But these dissonant
moods also get edited out of memory; we’ll
remember the view over the ocean longer than
the slight queasiness which turned us in on
ourselves at the time. Our minds are cavernous,
chaotic places. So much courses through them
that has little to do with what is right in
front of our eyes. We can end up seeming ungrateful
to where are. Someone is telling us an important
story, and not from any evil, just from the
difficulty of having to manage the entity
called ‘I’, we digest some regret or other
instead. We are at a beautiful location, but
we can barely take in the vegetation and the
extraordinary views, so fixated are we on
an event that will occur in six months time.
We need to be prepared for the weird way in
which we align with the world and not berate
ourselves unduly for our difficulties at doing
justice to where our bodies and minds happen
to be. We should be ready for this disloyalty
in other people too – at moments when they
look strangely worried at a party we’ve
laid on or don’t seem to be listening to
a story we are telling them. They too may
just be experiencing some of the major difficulties
of being in the present. Like us, they’ll
probably enjoy our encounter with us so much
more when the present has safely given way
to memory.